e
e e
all right good morning everyone it's
9:00 welcome to Jael
car um I'd like to uh thank all the
legislative members of the committee for
their work on overturning The veto of
House Bill
1622 which has happened and therefore
it's it is now law and we don't have to
worry about those details again
all right so the
um
Alternatives Senator gray you can sit in
for Senator
Lang and representative grassy can sit
in for representative
Schmidt representative L I said she's on
her way so representative hacken
Phillips you can sit in for Senator
Whitley
okay the minutes of the previous
meeting is there a motion so moved all
right moved by Senator uh Ward and
seconded by representative groa any any
corrections additions or
deletions all right seeing none those in
favor I those
opposed all right and the consent
agenda does anyone have something to
remove from the consent
agenda seeing none is there a
motion move to approve by Senator
chandley second
re seconded by representative Lynn I
think was
first any comments
discussion those in favor I
opposed all right thank you thank you
very much all right representative
Schmidt has
arrived
so Senator
inis okay
yes ah well in that case we will have a
crowd all
right all right
on the regular agenda
Bingo uh so the first item is from the
Lottery
Commission the commission did submit a
conditional approval which
addressed most of the comments um but
there were still some remaining as there
was uh 14 forms with this 62 page rule
so catching everything was a little
difficult um but I have been in contact
with Valerie King to go over the
discrepancies between the form and the
rule text that were missed um there were
a couple editorial fixes and then one
editorial unclear on page 10 of the
conditional approval request um due to
some missing language um in the rule
text from the form certification and
based on our conversations it's my
understanding that the commission's
going to ask for an oral conditional
approval to address those
items um and I can go over each one
individually or I can go right to the
last issue with this particular rule I
think we can trust the two of you to
sort through the form issues as long as
there's an agreement okay uh what is are
there any other issues the only other
remaining issue is there's a note to
jail car um and a legislative intent
comment on the first page of the
conditional approval which was carried
over from the final final proposal um in
the commission's notice that was filed
with the initial proposal indicated that
these rules are to address statutory
amendments but these statutory
amendments were made back in
2021 um and then additionally there were
some further amendments that were made
in
2023 so there is a question about why
there was a delay in implementing the
2021 and 202 three amendments and this
kind of also ties into to a note to the
committee on page 13 of the final
proposal where there was a statutory
amendment in 2016 to the amount that
private campgrounds and hotels could
charge for special bingo games from $2
to $5 but it wasn't until this
particular proposal that the commission
updated that amount so it seems like
there's been some delays in updating the
rules to reflect statutory
changes good
morning yes sorry good morning my name
is Valerie King I'm the director of the
investigations and compliance division
over at New Hampshire lottery that is
the unit that overseas charitable gaming
um delays in implementing the
legislative changes can be laid solely
on me I am the in addition to my duties
as the Director of the division uh I
also am the sole rule writer for the
agency and in the past few years you may
be aware that the gaming rules have um
we've had a lot of changes into our
agency with regards to legislation we've
had sports betting in
2019 we had historic horse racing added
in
2021 which um we promulgated rules as
quickly as we could for those but since
2021 we've had 23 new law changes and
the most recent in 2024 there were eight
so we've had a lot going on and so I
have been we've although the rules have
not changed we do make sure that our
lenses are aware of the statutory
changes we have newsletters we send out
email blasts to make sure that they are
aware of those changes and we do not com
make them comply with rules that do not
you know because laws over supersede the
the rules so we make sure they're aware
of any of those changes
um we've also been doing a lot of
changes internally to change our
processes this as um uh attorney Ricard
mentioned we have a lot of forms we've
been revising a lot of those forms and
our processes to make it easier for
primarily our Charities to apply for
example I
recently um there was some legislative
changes to make sure that the definition
of a charitable organization is a stame
across all game types this would allow
us to change our process to give
Charities would be um apply to be
eligible for all game types and once
found eligible they can just um request
game dates which so we are trying to
make a lot of changes and that has
slowed down our ability to to keep up
with um legislative changes to the and
and reflected in the
rules thank you any questions
does someone have a motion move to
approve second all right move by Senator
Li can we just make sure though that
when we move to approve that we have
their agreement that they're going to as
part of the
motion that there we have their
agreement to work on the forms and to
come to an agreement yes
absolutely that that is what you meant
correct that's what I okay yes seconded
by representative Len I'm wondering if
we need to redo the seating of
alternates for regular members you yes I
did because Senator Lang is now in and
some else can make the motion well
you're here you're a member okay okay um
yes the I believe it was representative
grassy was sitting for Senator Lang
um actually it's Senator gray who's
sitting for uh Senator Lang um Senator
uh excuse me representative grassy was
sitting for representative Schmidt but
is now sitting for Senator I see so we
have five house members who are here
three senators and alternates for repes
Senator Whitley and Senator Enis correct
correct okay and then we
have three yes
Senator Madam chair yes one of the house
members is sitting in for Senator I
think that maybe we should rise that
agreed okay
Senator gray you should sit in for
Senator Andis then and who and
representative H Grassi is in for Sen
for repres Senator Whitley correct
okay
what he was sitting for Senator Lang who
has
arrived okay
so Senate represent hackin Phillips is
still sitting in for representative
Whitley Senator gray is sitting in for
Senator inis and representative grassy
is available as
need is that correct everyone
clear okay sorry about the confusion I
wasn't aware of who all was going to be
here all right so Senator Lang has made
a motion to approve with the
understanding that the discrepancies
between the form and forms and the rules
will be negotiated with the staff
seconded by representative Lynn is there
any any
discussion those in favor I opposed all
right thank you very much and good luck
thank you very much and I just like to
add um that attorney Ricard has been
very helpful in this process and I
believe that it's a better product in
the end thanks to her thank you thank
you
right just as a matter of formality uh
uh so
Cecil when when U Miss king um nods her
head are you getting that down that
she's effectively voting yes are you
getting that down
okay thank you representative
Schmidt Department of energy
uh so this is final proposal 24 202 2492
energy 300 rules this one is a very
unique situation in that um there were
some substantive comments on the final
proposal the agency did submit a
conditional approval which addressed all
the substantive comments but then
subsequently submitted an amended
conditional approval with additional
changes after talking to one of the
stakeholders is one of the utilities um
and those changes resulted in more
substantive comments from me um and so
the department has today brought which I
placed on each of your uh seats um a
revised amended conditional approval
which they will be requesting orally
today showing the changes to address my
comments and then also some additional
housekeeping changes um I did talk with
attorney binon
before the meeting and we went over
these changes they do address my
comments um so on the amended
conditional approval so I have nothing
further to
add yes Senator just to make sure we got
all that right um we had we had a final
Proposal with comments they gave a
conditional approval that was okay
originally then they made some further
changes to their conditional approval
which caused more comments they've
corrected the comments with the written
WR version after your conversation they
have addressed the amended conditional
approval issues and now we have a new
version in front of us that you're okay
with that's correct thank you all
right good morning um Madame chair and
members of the committee my name is
Marie Helen balson and um I'm an
attorney with the Department of
energy um and um I would also say thank
you to attorney rard for working um very
hard hard in all these different changes
which uh we take seriously um
stakeholders have um submit uh comment
uh during the public comment period and
after and um and and we we look at them
closely um as uh as background um on
October 10th um we filed our amended
request for conditional approval
addressing all of the prior comments and
edits however very closely after we
submitted our amended request for
conditional approval we received an
additional request for further language
clarification from ever Source whose
attorney is in the um audience here
today and um you know won't Vol in toer
him for questions but um he is here um
this prompted us to further amend
several sections and then submit again
to OS um the impact Ed sections which
are in the packets before you and the
form um are
en36
06f en 30606 H1 and2 and form
e5e as attorney records said one of
those further revisions caused
substantive comments um from attorney
Ricard and also upon further review of
those sections and form e5e attorney
record found inconsistencies between the
form e5e and sections en 30606 and en
30806 sorry we believe that we have
addressed the 's concerns and and we can
explain how relative to the substantive
um uh uh comment if you look at your
packet at
en36
06f which is the requirement for
utilities to notify the department
within two hours after becoming aware of
an accident
um there ever Source requested that the
accident result in a substantial
degradation of operations and safety if
you take a look at
f2 the word substantial was cited as
over Brad and vague by OS we rewarded
the word substantial to State um
degradation of operations of safety that
affects 500 customers or more with an
expected duration in excess of 12 hours
the was satisfactory to the department
and EV source and um I believe attorney
requir as
well um I can also discuss a little bit
about the forms um uh upon review of
that section and the reporting
requirements at en
30606 H1 and2 if you look closely at
Pages uh 17 and 18 attorney Ricard noted
that the form e5e which is also in the
packet um
had some discrepancies with the rules
language in H1 we have made the form and
Rule consistent such that utilities must
file an accident report
um the form E5 within five business days
of notification of an accident and in H2
we've made the form consistent with u
the detailed follow-up report being made
automatically within 15 days of the
accident there were similar concerns
that Ian um 3086 regarding discrepancies
in reporting timelines with the e5e
accident reporting form and those have
been
addressed um finally eversource
requested language changes at um en
30606 J that's page 18 which we have
included this was to make it consistent
with the provision at308
06b primarily that if a death um occurs
as a result of a reported accident and
is known to the utility
then the utility is required to report
this fact in an additional
report um finally we we would also like
to note for the committee that the
department has begun rulemaking by
filing um uh
uh en 20115 rule the department filed
for fiscal impact statement and initial
Proposal with the LBA relative to this
rule on 1016 24
yesterday our understanding and
expectation um is that we'd be at the
January Jael car and that the Pu
procedural rules aim to be at the
January 25 Jael car meeting as well
um the new Department rule en2 105 will
hopefully be approved at the same time
um as the puc rule whether that's
January 25 or in an earlier date um
um if if the um Ru making proceeds even
more speedily and we happen to be at
Janu uh December
jar H and this will eliminate the
concern about a lapse in the
Department's authority to wave rules a
comment was made in this rule set where
en 20115 is referenced
twice um we updated for jelar that we
would be in the rulemaking process
relative to2015 but wanted to report
about the more expedited trajectory
um and so for those reasons um and that
explanation we um hope that the um
committee will approve our request for
oral conditional approval thank
you comments questions representative
Broda thank you you noted in your
convers in your um testimony that in
306 F where you Define substantial as
more than where is that correct in the
rules do you have the packet in front of
you because it's a very hot off the
press and we printed it off this morning
yeah apologies that's okay that's okay
it's been dayto day um trying to and if
you go to page um page 18 I believe um
no um sorry 17 yep yep 17 it's F2 and um
we've struck um substantial and then
we've added that um yes thank you I see
it thank you so
much Senator so on your new rule F
F2 it says that affects 500 customers or
more with an expected duration
exceeding
um no never mind I I think I answer my
own question but we read it again you're
good thank you sorry well I'm glad to
know the careful uh work will will
straighten it out I'm a little concerned
that while you're very rapidly
responding to some customers the other
customers and affected uh people don't
get a chance to look at these new rules
and have you considered it how it might
affect
them well I I think you know we we went
through the regular rulemaking process
and
um doing our best to accommodate uh the
uh utilities uh last minute requests um
that's you know that's as far as we've
gotten yeah all
right representative L um thank you
madam chairman and thank you very much I
live in a pretty populated area so 500
customers is um seems reasonable to me I
just wanted to make sure that in other
areas of the state that that is also
appropriate um because I know referring
from my area to others doesn't always
work
m in even in less populated areas 500
customers is significant yeah I would
say 400 I would say 499 is pretty
significant I mean th this is one of
those situations where
technically we're seeing 500 but if
you've got 400 and and 87 those people
are going to be very unhappy uh and even
if doesn't technically meet the standard
so how are we handling that is yes is
there any restriction on reporting
something that does not meet this
definition M Jarry you're asking if they
can also report it there 400 if they
want to yeah that's what I want to make
sure yeah yeah okay well here you go
it's also is involves aircraft trains
commercial boats closure of a state
highway considering how how many of them
we have there's that covers a lot
anticipated to be reported publicly I I
think that we're covered for the
good Madam chair yes move to approve the
amended amended conditional approval
thank you amended amended
amended seconded by representative Leon
any further discussion
comments all right seeing no
those in favor I
opposed thank you very
much all right
Dr um before we move to the next item
we've had a request for public testimony
from a representative from the puc just
to clarify the filing of their 200 rules
oh please yes we yes good morning I'm
Sarah Fuller I'm a I'm a senior adviser
attorney to the Public Utilities
Commission and their uh rulemaking
representative
the Public Utilities Commission is going
to submit their final proposal um in
December so uh we had hoped maybe it
would be November it's not going to be
November probably because our comment
period we've extended comment period uh
through October 22nd I understand that
we would have to flip our 200 proposal a
few days later to get it in November the
180 days would put us on the December
meeting the agreement that the Public
Utilities Commission has worked out um
with the Department of energy is that if
their proposal which we have worked
diligently with them and supported them
to PR to prepare and submit to fiscal
impact on their waiver if that is not
ready to be approved until January what
we would do is we would submit for
hopeful approval in December with an
adoption date in January which will
allow them to continue to use pu
20.05 as their w
uh going forward because of RSA 12 p14
which allows them to rely and use pu
rules unless they are amended so I just
because of the timing issues I just
wanted to put on the record very clearly
that it isn't the intent of the Public
Utilities Commission to have our
procedural um rules proposed in final
format and be here in December to
discuss those with you and and if the
department of energy uh needs another
month to um go through the process to
get their waiver rule that's of course
something that we would work with them
as sister agencies to make sure that
they're not left without rules um but
how we would do that is we would just uh
delay our effective date on our adopted
rule so I just wanted to clarify um for
the committee and thank you for your
time all right any
questions all right thank you very much
for clarifying find that we
uh wondering what's been happening to
those
rules all right back to the
Dr so this is uh proposal 2024 138 on
meals and rentals tax and um this
actually should have been on consent I
had two comments that you can still see
in your packet for the final proposal um
turns out it's just my ignorance in the
in the field that caused these comments
uh my first is on
32 um I was concerned because it was
allowing operators to um ask for cash
for the taxes upon paying with a credit
card um but this is not a requirement
it's a option and it allows them to
um deal with the the the fees that come
from from doing a credit card action and
my other comment was about um filing for
a extension on a tax return and I did
not know that if you file an extension
you have to pay the tax before you do
the I I've never been laid on my taxes
so I didn't know that was a thing so
those comments are no longer relevant
and so I have no other comments okay are
there any questions from the committee
concerns motion to approve all right has
been moved by representative hackin
Phillips second by Senator Lang
questions
comments those in favor I
opposed okay thank you very
much and other other
business we have an expedited
repeal um actually that's an emergency
rule emergency rule oh I'm sorry
emergency HHS we have emergency rule yes
I'll discuss it briefly and then let the
uh Department fill in the details
um this is an a rule to require
Interstate criminal record checks for uh
licens exempt child care providers
currently people in the home and the
providers themselves have to have
criminal record checks this would
require it uh for Interstate under
certain circumstances
it's required uh by federal law and it
is in the new um state plan which just
uh was implemented at the beginning of
this month
um is there a possibility that the
department could have realized that they
would need rules for this earlier ye yes
but uh the program did not realize that
and now they need the rules in place or
they'll be in violation of the state
plan and uh the Federal Regulations
which would uh subject the department to
a 5% penalty which could be more than
$900,000
good morning Nicole Valena rules
coordinator for the Department of Health
and Human
Services and I'm Brian Clark general
counsel for the Bureau of Child
Development and Head Start
collaboration so yes uh the Bureau of
child devel vment has been working um on
coming into compliance with the new
federal rule um we had been working on
the New Hampshire um connection
information system which is the computer
system which will be a One-Stop place to
have background checks done and it'll be
able to cover in state and out of state
and so the new requirement is to use
that system because it's the only way we
can do out of state background checks
and otherwise we we just wouldn't be
able to comply with the rule um and it's
rather unfortunate that we did not
realize that we were missing this
component we were focused on the New
Hampshire uh connections information
system we weren't focused on the rule
and that was an oversight and we didn't
realize until September 18th um at which
point we took Swift action to do an
emergency
rule any questions or comments
okay so if I understand this correctly
this is to do criminal background checks
on licensed
exempt
providers that's
correct wondering what the benefit of
being licensed exempt is if they still
have to go through all the background
checks and so forth other than the fee
of course state law currently requires
the background checks uh this will be
expanded to out of state as
well so if an individual has lived in a
state other than New Hampshire within
the previous five years this is now the
capacity to to check that criminal
background record check oh thank you
very much yeah sure of course okay
representative Lon uh thank you madam
chair um as I was looking through it
seemed like there were a lot of changes
within this um emergency rule are all of
those changes necessary in order order
to meet that Federal deadline or was
anything else added in alongside it yeah
aside from editorial like gender pronoun
things like that everything else is
correcting the website it was an expired
outdated website a lot of text you saw
extracted was the very detailed former
process that was paper uh and didn't
allow for Interstate background record
checks so yes it does look like a lot of
text but it is connected to this right
now thank
you anyone else
all right thank you I don't we don't we
don't have to do anything to the
emergency rule so that's
that all right thank you is there
anything else from
anyone director moral uh three quick
things first I'd like to thank the uh
committee members for the good turnout
earlier this week we only had three
members committed so we were a concerned
um like to remind the committee that
next month uh we'll be taking up the um
Ed 306 School approval rules uh one you
heard last month but uh postponed to
November and the other Provisions will
also be up in
November um also for those of you that
were not here uh last month this is
Douglas aout uh some of you may know him
anyways from the work he's done for oplc
uh he is now the new me uh because I'm
retiring after uh next month's
meeting and uh I will be leading it in
very good hands all right thank you and
we can probably uh cancel the continued
meeting all right let's do that that
would
uh
and so we will meet again in
November and our terms do expire in the
beginning of December when the session
the the session ends so we will need to
speak to the speaker of the house and
the Senate President whoever that may
be to appoint a jail car very quickly so
that we can have the December meeting
yes and I've spoken with the the Chiefs
of Staff in both the House and Senate to
to remind them of that fact okay yes
all right and thank you very much and
have a good weekend